I now use this analogy the jockey and
the horse if I both really love the
business and understand it and I believe
that the human behind it is capable I've
done incredibly well when I like one of
the two I do very bad when I'm like oh
this person's capable but I don't love
the idea sometimes I'm like well she or
he will figure it out and a lot of times
that hasn't worked out sometimes it does
but Evan Williams and Twitter Mark
Zuckerberg in Facebook was the one I had
the most conviction about Brian and
coinbase what I'm very good at is I'm
willing to bet on things before it
happened because I have a good sense of
can it stay alive the reason I didn't
bet on a lot of VR companies is I don't
think VR companies are going to stay
alive because I think we're eight years
away and I don't think they have the
runway and I don't think they'll get the
traction four years ago when I'm like
man is AI close I met with like 20 30
startups and what I realized was it
wasn't happening the next year some of
it was machine learning and solid but it
wasn't chat GPT but what all those
meanings did is they allowed me to the
second I saw chat gbt a year ago I'm
like this is it because I knew the
difference and I knew the path of how it
got there